c'est non les chroniques de la haine
ordinaire
[Musique]
tous ces gens qui font des métiers
publics sont des vendus
manu dibango lui-même n'est pas blanc
blanc
en ce qui me concerne moi même
personnellement dans mon ego tout seul
en tant que l'individu isolé moi même
je suis prêt à faire mon vélo critiquent
je pas de permis de conduire
je le reconnais je touche des
pots-de-vin des grands pots de grands
vins
mais il faut me comprendre on a beau
avoir sa dignité être un homme d'honneur
et de probité c'est à dire un homme qui
refuse de se faire [ __ ] à moins de
50 mille francs hors taxes la passe
il arrive que parfois le chant des
sirènes se fasse trop quand vous temps
je vous narre parce que vous me faites
marrer
il ya quelques semaines j'ai fait
allusion ici en toute innocence à l'un
des plus grands vins de france et donc
du monde du monde vraiment ce ne sont
pas les des hausses trop italien mais
analyser ou les californiens avec leur
cabernet à cautériser les écorchures qui
oseront me contredire
il s'agissait de château figeac premier
grand cru classé de saint-émilion dont
je célébrais étourdiment les mérites
tout en fustigeant une [ __ ] aqua fil
de mes relations que je vais mettre de
l'eau dedans
une semaine plus tard j'ai reçu par le
biais des ptt
d'une société qui s'occupe
éventuellement d'acheminer parfois du
courrier on a toujours trop tendance à
l'oublier
la preuve le met encore parvenus pas
plus tard qu'hier une facture de 5 mille
balles de téléphone
j'ai reçu 10 heures avant d'être assez
grossièrement interrompu par moi même
pour une dégression sournoisement charge
et d'hostilité à l'encontre d'un service
public méritants et sans lequel on ne
saurait où trouver ces indispensables
calendrier avec des photos de bébés
chats couchés sur des
et on respire déjà couchés sur des poufs
pouf
j'ai reçu une lettre donc de
saint-émilion qui commençait par la plus
alléchante d entrée en matière château
figeac le
set les 17 en substance que ma façon
désinvolte de célébrer souvent les
mérites de ce breuvage sur les ondes car
hélas non mon père ce n'était pas la
première fois il n'était pas tombé dans
l'oreille d'un buveur d'eau mais dans
celle de monsieur thierry manoncourt le
propriétaire du cru qui me proposait
d'aller visiter ses chais ce qui n'est
guère compromettant mais aussi de
m'envoyer un cadeau ce qu'il est
foutrement plus
mais il y a pire si vous vous étiez
contenter cher monsieur manoncourt de
m'imposer votre cadeau en me l'envoyant
à france inter par la poste suite et
sans danger vous savez bien que vos vins
ne demande qu à vieillir dans des wagons
de boire en bras j'ai voulu s'y est mis
devant le fait accompli je n'aurais en
rien participé à l'inadmissible
corruption que vous avez cyniquement
perpétré au détriment de mon honneur
bafoué dans les ultimes sursaut surnage
désormais aucun niveau d'un famille vous
l'avait jetée pantelant
mais non au lieu de cela vous me
demandiez où vous pourriez m'adresser le
fruit défendu de notre crime commun
de deux choses l'une ou bien je ne vous
répondrai pas fier et serein il
n'ébranle à bhl dans ma vertu pur et dur
face à la protée du destin je restais
alors seule au monde avec ma dignité
pour moi sur le chemin escarpé de la
félicité éternelle sans autre
intermédiaire entre dieu et moi même que
ce ver de contrexéville ou juste en vain
tenté de noyer mon chagrin
il est beaucoup plus difficile de noyer
son chagrin dans un verre de contrex que
d'étouffer l'affairé greenpeace dans un
sourire de fabius
ou bien je cédais je vous répondrai par
retour la honte au front et la fierté
sous le bras ma b 100 à 1000 salutations
empressé emile remerciements émus pour
votre exquise générosité en vous
communiquant mon adresse laitages le
numéro de code le nom et le prénom de la
concierge en cas d'absence à l'heure des
repas et en y joignant une photo de moi
dédicacé afin que vous ne vous trompiez
pas de clients et un exemplaire d'un de
mes livres avec un signe et à la page où
j'ai cité plusieurs fois le nom de
figeac et une photo de la mère de mes
enfants à la plage on sait jamais
finalement j'ai trouvé une solution
intermédiaire cher monsieur manancourt
je vous ai adressé la lettre suivante
sur papier à en-tête de chez moi
cher monsieur votre lettre le plonge
dans l'embarras je comprends fort bien
dans quel esprit vous me proposez
chaleureusement un cadeau mais ne
serais-je point vénale en acceptant
d'autre part s'il est vrai que je ne
mange pas de ce pain là j'aurais du mal
à me convaincre que je ne vois pas de ce
vingt six
tout bien réfléchi il ne m'apparaît pas
que l'homme puisse se compromettre en
acceptant de partager le vin avec autrui
ce n'est pas dieu qui me contredira si
le sens de son fils avait été de figeac
je n'aurais jamais sombrer dans
l'athéisme
veuillez agréer et c'est à quelques
temps de là monsieur le maître de chais
de château figeac maintenant c'est qu'il
avait l'avantagé de me prévenir de
l'imminence de l'arrivée chez moi d'une
caisse de vin de la part de monsieur et
madame manon cours
le colis est là dans ma cave en assez
bonne compagnie je crois il s'appelle au
frais pour quelques jours encore on ne
se jette pas sur une femme épuisée d'un
long voyage en train on attend que ce
soit reposée allongé seul dans le noir
avant de la soulever par le cou pour y
poser la bouche que les expéditeurs de
cette caisse en bois trouvent ici
l'expression de ma gratitude et qu'ils
veuillent bien ne lire entre les lignes
de cette lettre ouverte sans leur accord
qu'un sourire de bonne compagnie tomber
des lèvres gourmandes d'un amoureux
transi modeste mais perdu pour les
inestimables splendeur aspirer des
graves terre volcanique que charrie
lille et la drones jusqu'au bord de
votre village ou la famille figé à cus
faisait déjà son vin blanc 300 c'est à
dire plus de 1600 ans 1 que les
pharmacologues de chez coca cola est
essayé en vain de détourner les
meilleurs d'entre nous des vignes du
seigneur pour leur faire siphonner leur
potion merdique
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour capter mais ils font rien
qu'à me lire dans nos campagnes
[Musique]
à la
fête non
[Musique]